These days. I'm thinking in animating about messages.
We cannot read on cracked codes, if you will. Apparently this topics in the air,
what with the release of the imitation game this month that films about Alan
Turing and crypt analysis of those German enigma machines during World War II.
I say cryptanalysis and not cryptography or where do you may know better because
cryptography is about sending a message securely by changing it,
often changing it so it looks meaningless.
This is obviously useful when there's a way for the receiver to change it back
and see the original message.
Crypt analysis on the other hand works out ways to understand and break those
systems to understand how the message is being changed by the system so that you
unintended recipient with your prying eyes can read the original message,
but this is all my brother's field.
I should grab him and Youtube can chat about it sometime.
It's all separate from decipherment,
which is an attempt to recover messages in an unknown writing system.
Crypt analysis works with texts that were meant to allude you.
Decipherment works with messages that were once plainly readable but aren't
anymore. Thanks to accidents of history.
So as you'll see in next Friday's video, which contains both hidden codes,
often use characters we recognize to hide a secret message on deciphered scripts
have characters we can't even read or identify that stand between us and a not
so secret or not intentionally secret message. Of course,
there is that Pesky Voynich manuscript, which may be both.
With all this in mind,
you've got a bit of background you appreciate next week's video.
I'd like to take the time to welcome all new subscribers.
You're making it so much fun to talk about language here.
Big smiles for all of you.
And let me know in the comments if you're interested in continuing this topic
with the short series that looks deeper at the decipherment of writing systems
like Egyptian and Myon.